Last August, I was told that in all likelihood, I had three to six months left to live.
I'm on month nine now.
And I'm not gonna get down and do any push-ups,...
...but there will be a short pick-up basketball game later.
Somebody said to me in light of these numbers,...
"Wow! So, you're really beating the Grim Reaper."
And what I said without even thinking about it is,...
"We don't beat the Reaper by living longer."
"We beat the Reaper by living well,...
...and living fully."
For the Reaper will come for all of us.
The question is,...
...what do we do between the time we're born and the time he shows up?
'Cause when he shows up, it's too late to do all the things...
...that you're always gonna kind of get around to.
So, I think the only advice I can give you...
...on how to live your life well...
...is first off, remember,...
...it's a cliche but I love cliches,...
..."It is not the things we do in life that we regret on our deathbed,...
...it is the things we do not."
'Cause I assure you I've done a lot of really stupid things,...
...and none of them bother me.
All the mistakes,...
...and all the dopey things,...
...and all the times I was embarrassed,...
...they don't matter.
What matters is that I can kinda look back and say,...
"Pretty much anytime I got a chance to do something cool,...
...I tried to grab for it."
And that's where my solace comes from.